but the dodgers have the elder statesman
clayton
kershaw making his 12th start of the
year the 33-year-old left-hander seven
up three down and erf
under three it'll be austin slater to
lead off for the giants
and he slams this one into left field at
base hit and that's how this game gets
started
giants get going and here is donovan
solano and he slams this one into center
field at base hit
the giants have two men on with nobody
out kershaw's in trouble in the top half
of the first
bringing wilmer flores to the plate in
the dirt
and both runners are going to advance so
the giants with
nobody out now have runners at second
and third got him
swinging as
first down for foreign kershaw evan
longoria stepping in get on the ground
giants are going to come up with a run
longoria picks up an rbi
giants have a one nothing lead here's
mauricio dubon
the giants offensively have really been
swinging the bats early in the count and
that's something that we've seen in
particular against kershaw
and he hits a high drive to left
down the line and out of here
part two run
and now the giants have three runs home
in the first inning against kershaw
now the left-handed hitting stephen
duggar stepping in
swings and misses to andy but the giants
strike for three the key swing a home
run from mauricio dubai kevin gausman in
his second season with the giants and
here in his
ninth year as a pro that one five three
era not just third in the national
league but by far his career best
chris taylor to lead off against gosman
taylor hits a pop-up
and wilmer flores is going to put it
away max monsieur with another home run
against the giants yesterday
fastball strike three call 96 miles an
hour with
movement running to the outside and
there's two out brings up matt
batey fastball is swung on lifted to
right field back just a couple of steps
later
waiting for it and he's got it inning
over three up three down
shut down inning there for guardsman now
gazman's ready to go to work against
bellinger and the dodgers in the bottom
of the second
splinter struck him out swinging wow
that one not only plummeted downward but
it also broke away
that's just a nasty pitch so one away
second strikeout for guardsman and here
is gavin lux
right center field towards the gap in
over double
dodgers have their first base run over
the game a ringing double from gavin lux
and it will bring up albert splitter
swung on and missed
he struck him out zach mckinstry coming
up
splitter is hit right to the shortstop
dubon in a couple of hops
and he throws him out at first so dupont
was in the perfect spot as has been the
case
all year osman with runners in scoring
position
is virtually unhittable clayton kershaw
gave up three in the first then went one
two three in the second keeping up his
season-long trend of when there's been
an issue it typically has come in the
first
inning it'll be austin slater who opened
up the game with the base hit
that one is hit hard to right center
field going back on it is ballinger
still going back it is gone
up over the right center field wall
austin slater with that signature
opposite field power four nothing giants
here in the third
two scoreless innings for kevin gausman
who's trying to get his tenth start out
of his 11 with
zero or one run allowed he throws a
great splitter swung on and missed
strike three
that had that screw ball movement diving
away from the left-handed hitter that is
just phenomenal
from kevin gausman his fourth strikeout
of the game
and the first two reach for san
francisco here in the fourth well
kershaw's struggling today not unlike
the way uria struggled yesterday
as curt casalli steps in that's the 1-0
fly
a pop-up into shallow center field
muncie running out over the shoulder
he's got it
and an over-the-shoulder catch a
beautiful play made by
max mudsey muncie caught it for a big
first
out mike talkman coming up bounces on to
first pujols to the bag
two up and now gausman comes up with
second and third but two down
job trying to put the ball in play slaps
a fastball into left field base head
coming in to score is dubois kevin
gausman knocks in a run
five nothing giants amazing
pitcher that came in with a great resume
and on a great roll
and he's continuing it here today the
pitch to bellinger
that is swung on and missed strike three
97 miles an hour with the fastball
fifth guardsman strikeout dave roberts
sticking with clayton kershaw
and he did the same thing with julio
urias they're really thinking long
term protecting the bullpen and the
usage down there but also keeping their
starters in
in good shape punches on right side
won't be an easy play
pujols feeds kershaw who beats solano to
the bag
they had to be perfect and albert to
kershaw they were
solano's out number one here's wilmer
flores flores lines the ball that's
caught by
muncie a couple of nice defensive plays
albert and clayton
and now muncie with some ups mckinstry
to lead off for the dodgers against
kevin gausman the giants leading five to
nothing
cosmon delivers high fastball struck him
out swinging
he put him away on three pitches six
strikeouts
for gaussman in four in the third
innings kevin gausman just two hits
allowed over five shutout innings
sixteen straight scoreless innings form
splitters
struck him out swinging wow
strikeout number seven he has been spot
on with his command today it's been so
impressive
two down nobody on here is matt beatty
of the change up bounce slowly up the
third base side guardsman off the mound
to get it
turns and fires to first out and first
what a play on both ends by gauzeman and
by flores boy everything is coming up
roses for gosling today
giants have faces loaded for one of
their hottest sitters in evan longoria
swung on and missed strike three
longoria down on strike first out of the
seventh
base is still loaded one away from
mauricio dubois he
strikes out new bond he just couldn't
lay off that fast ball
bearing in the knuckles and kelly's got
a chance to pass the ball on to gonzalez
and have the dodgers get out of this
inning unscathed
the hitter is duggar got him swinging
somehow they get out of it with no
damage kevin gausman
is done it was interesting watching him
come off the field after fielding this
ball after he looked like he was maybe
wincing if you wonder if something
happened here that has played a part in
his early departure
gosman has left the game because of left
hip tightness monsie's 18 game on base
streak
on the line here oh for three this
afternoon on this 2-0 from the tell
it's a high fly ball right center field
muncie does it to the giants again
it's a 5-2 game as they finally break
through in the eighth
his 100th as a big leaguer it is time
for
jake mckee to come in and try and close
this thing out one on one out for pujols
fly ball to left who holtz has hit it
out it's a one-run
game he was robbed of a home run on
friday night
there is nobody who is going to pill for
this one
it's five to four so two down and now
austin barnes
he's gonna try and do one thing you're
gonna try and tie it up
and a swing there's a pop fly shallow
right yostremski's
calling for it and he's got it and the
giants hang on
just barely